I decided to openly talk about micro
dosing because I had no idea how
positively it would have affected my
life
George Burk is a Silicon Valley
entrepreneur working in the field of
mind and body experimentation every
morning before he goes to work he
consumes a tiny bit of LSD about 1/10 as
strong as a typical dose with micro
dosing I don't really feel any effect I
don't know that I've really taken it
other than I noticed that my brain seems
to be able to solve problems a little
bit better than I was before
Burke has calibrated his dose so that it
merely tweaks his perception and doesn't
interfere with everyday tasks he's part
of an increasingly popular trend called
micro dosing and I'm feeling a little
more connected both to my work and to
the people that I need to talk to on a
given day let me tell you about the
first time that I did LSD micro vision I
had a big task I needed to take care of
putting together a large business
contingency plan it would have been
difficult to think about each
contingency and incubate it and put it
on paper this was going to be a very
large document that I was putting
together after micro dosing what I was
able to do and it's just intuitively
came to me was to envision each
contingency as branches of a tree and I
could picture each one as a branch and I
could visually climb this tree and reach
out to one branch grab that idea
incubate it write it down and then place
it back up and then go to the next
branch and I could do that all
throughout the entire tree and it was a
very interesting way to visually solve
what would have been a very complicated
problem to do otherwise
so it was interesting to me the thing
about rock climbing is that it's just as
mental as it is physical in fact you
want to minimize how physical you are by
using mental acuity to figure out the
right path to go up you want to optimize
that so that way you're not burning out
my grossing has helped with the ability
figure out what happen again on micro
dosing has even allowed him to taper off
his use of adderall micro dosing of
psychedelics LSD specifically has been
something that has allowed me to not
feel trapped in my current ADHD
medication that there's another answer
there's another way to be able to have a
cognitive enhancement the use of
psychedelics as productivity and
creativity hacks reaches back to the
very beginnings of Silicon Valley the
minute that you understand that you can
poke life and actually something will if
you push in something will pop out the
other side you can you can change you
can mold it that's maybe the most
important thing when Steve Jobs told his
biographer taking LSD was a profound
experience one of the most important
things in my life it was bound to have
an impact jobs willingness to speak out
helped inspire Burt to go public people
like Steve Jobs in his public advocacy
certainly is helped but it means people
have to actually step up and state what
they've been doing not just that there
has to be less repercussions from from
the government for for engaging in
activity that's illegal drug prohibition
has prevented scientists from studying
the effects of microtubule SD that
started to change migrate was originated
because Albert Hofmann who originated
LSD had tried of course all kinds of
doses in his lifetime and he actually
micro dosed for many years himself he
said it helped him think about his
thinking and he indicated this was an
under research area and I became
interested because it wasn't under
research area James Fadiman is an author
and researcher at sofa University in
Palo Alto
and he's gathering survey data from LSD
micro dosers about their experiences
what we've done is what I call search
which is here's some uses of
psychedelics that we don't really know
about a really understand all we seem to
know is that they're they matter to
people and they're very safe so we've
basically said to people we can suggest
how you can take it safely and
effectively in return you tell us how
it's working for you both with physical
conditions mental conditions and for
enhanced health people who are either
depressed or on antidepressants and
don't like it find that micro dosing in
many many cases turns around their
depression very very quickly
another area are people who are in the
creative arts or in the creative science
more who find that they function a
little better meaning they can basically
work slightly not necessarily more
creative but more time in in what's
called flow Fadiman isn't making any
empirical claims his hope is that
scientists will use his observations as
a starting point for further research
it's as if we've now discovered this new
world and we've mapped it a little bit
and now someone says well now let's get
the hard science under this and what I
hear from the research community is
they're ready to go George Burke hopes
that micro dosing will continue catching
on in Silicon Valley and Beyond with a
population of 300 million in the United
States imagine 1 percent of those people
are taking some form of cognitive
enhancer it's 3 million people who would
be able to solve problems better and
faster and with a better sense of
connectedness than we haven't seen
before what impact would that have on
America
I can't imagine but I think it would be
I think would be profound
[Music]
[Music]